for more on the significance of joe
biden's decision to put senator harris
on the ticket we are joined by cbs news
political contributors
jamal simmons and terry sullivan good
morning good to see you both
uh terry let me start with you um
our nation's first vice president john
adams famously said i am nothing but i
could be everything i wonder is this
selection
everything for former vice president
biden how transformative
is this for the presidential race right
now
this is the least surprising pick uh
imaginable for joe biden which fits into
joe biden he's not going to take a risk
uh and he doesn't need to right now i
mean it's it's been the conventional
wisdom that
that uh that senator harris was the best
pick
uh was the uh that checked all the boxes
she's been vetted
uh and so this was a a safe pick for him
so
you know it's he any i mean he doesn't
need a risky pick
at this point in time same question to
you jamal how transformative
is this pick how does this change the
dynamics of this race going forward
good morning vlad and terry listen i
think this is uh one of the most
dynamic exciting picks sometimes you
pick a candidate for geographic reasons
she's from california doesn't really
matter as much democrats going to win
that state
there's a demographic reason obviously
because she's a woman the first
african-american the first
asian-american woman to sit on the
ticket there's also a psychographic
reason joe biden needs to
touch the cord of excitement in
democrats that has been a little bit
low for the last few months people
wanted to beat donald trump they felt
confident in joe biden they think he can
do the job
but if you talk to people the level of
excitement just wasn't there
my feeds yesterday whether it was
twitter or instagram or my personal
texts
were going off the charts even joe biden
said he raised some of the most money
most money that he raised
the entire campaign yesterday after he
uh made this announcement
democrats are excited about this ticket
they are ready to go i think
that matters so terry if you were
advising
uh president trump's campaign go ahead
terry go ahead
well i was just going to say i mean if
twitter mattered well it doesn't so i
mean
you know the energy on twitter doesn't
matter the worst thing that could happen
to joe biden
is energy about joe biden's campaign i
mean look this race
is the best thing for joe biden is this
race is a referendum on donald trump
and that's why he's been hiding in his
basement wisely
for the last six months at the end of
the day
he has to pick boring picks like senator
harris
because if he does anything
unconventional if he does anything risky
if he does anything
exciting he's going to become the center
of attention and he can't withstand the
spotlight
that is is what they're concerned about
so they're just they're they're like
a a sec football team
that is 40 points ahead at halftime
they just need to run out the clock and
sit on the ball and and not
do any turnovers
yeah i got to tell you i've never never
in the history
never in the history of politics have i
ever heard anybody say
that not that excitement was a bad thing
for a candidate
never have i ever heard that this is the
most exciting thing
don adams famously said i am nothing but
i could be
everything i wonder is this selection
everything for former vice president
biden how transformative
is this for the presidential race right
now
this is the least surprising pick uh
imaginable for joe biden which fits into
joe biden he's not going to take a risk
and he doesn't need to right now i mean
it's it's been the conventional wisdom
that
that uh that senator harris was the best
pick
uh was the uh that checked all the boxes
she's been vetted
uh and so this was a safe pick for him
so
you know it's he any he doesn't need a
risky pick at this point in time
same question to you jamal how
transformative is this pick how does
this change the dynamics
of this race going forward good morning
vlad and terry listen i think this is uh
one of the most dynamic exciting picks
but sometimes you pick a candidate for
geographic reasons she's from california
it doesn't really matter as much
democrats going to win that state
um there's a demographic reason
obviously because she's a
is she a generation xr or she a baby
boomer i think she lives in that nether
world
between the two of those generations but
for those of us who are generation xers
it feels like the first candidate
from our generation that could actually
take national leadership
all right so terry some republicans are
already attacking uh kamala harris as
somebody with extreme
positions will that argument stick with
voters
uh you know it's yet to be seen i mean
the problem that the trump campaign has
is they find the campaign finds a decent
message
uh that would work uh and then their
number one messenger
strays off and talks about everything
else except for that message
so i think it could work she does have
some extreme liberal positions
and the question is is uh
you know donald trump going to stick
with that message or is he going to
wander off talking about
you know former staffers who write
tell-all books and that's that's the
problem
the fundamental problem with the trump
campaign thus far
terry in your view what are some of
those extreme positions
look guns i mean she's she's uh
she's very restrictive on uh for uh
second amendment rights
um on uh the life issue uh
on i mean just across the board she's
got
some uh left of mainstream i mean she's
a
senator from one of the more liberal
states in the country
you know you don't you don't get uh get
elected there by being a moderate
mainstream democrat
but jamal it's interesting to me um
the president has attacked her for uh
her
remarks made during justice kavanaugh's
nomination
um she's been attacked for being what
some people say
you see a lot of this on social media
they call her a cop because of her
positions
as a prosecutor take me through how she
overcomes some of those challenges
listen that's going to be probably her
biggest challenge you know many
commentators are saying she's going to
help with young voters that's true to a
point
i think she's very helpful with voters
over the age of 30 maybe over the age of
35
but those voters who are 18 to 29
especially
voters of color particularly men of
color in 18 to 29
which are the place where donald trump
is trying to kind of shave off a few of
these votes on his criminal justice
record which is flawed by the way but
he's going to try to do it those people
are very suspicious of her time
as a police as a prosecutor she's got to
make the case which i think she does
have some evidence
that she tried to be a reformer as a
prosecutor and now the question is
what's she going to do going forward and
she understands some of the limitations
of the criminal justice system on the
other hand
women over the age of 35 over the age of
you know
50 people my aunt's age who are 70
all think that this is the most
groundbreaking wonderful thing so i i
think that she will
she will have this question about
criminal justice reform but she's got to
get
the question back to donald trump the
160 000 people who've died because of
coronavirus
and talking about whether or not we're
going to have competent management in
the in the government and a future
that democrats and everybody in the
country women in particular in the
suburbs
can move forward with
terry sullivan and jamal simmons always
great to talk to you both thanks so much
for joining us
good talk to you guys